[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend die
zwei Sensationsnachrichten des Tages
kennen Sie sicher Deutschland ist
Basketball Weltmeister und bei den
Fußballern wurde Hansi Flick gefeuert
beiden Sport Ereignissen widmen wir uns
natürlich im Laufe der Sendung noch
ausführlich aber die Weltlage ist dann
doch leider so dass wir jetzt erstmal
nach Marokko schauen man musste es
gestern ja schon befürchten als bereits
in den ersten 24 Stunden nach dem Leben
so hohe Toten Zahlen gemeldet wurde die
bittere Erfahrung mit solchen
Katastrophen lehrt ja dass es dann am
Ende noch viel viel mehr sein werden
heute berichten die marokkanischen
Behörden bereits über mehr als 2000
Opfer eine Art und Anna Warsberg
Berichten aus einem schwer getroffenen
Land
es sind diese engen verwinkelten Gassen
die die Altstadt von Marrakesch
ausmachen das zu Hause von griesiger sie
nimmt uns mit vorbei an den
Trümmerhaufen hier haben es ihr Mann und
sie gerade noch rechtzeitig aus dem Haus
geschafft als es anfing zu beben seitdem
schlafen die beiden draußen
ich war drinnen als ich um 23 Uhr ein
Geräusch gehört habe und gesehen habe
dass die Decke Herunterfallen würde und
sobald ich den ersten Fuß vor die Tür
gesetzt habe ist die Decke eingestürzt
sie fiel auf die Küche und das ganze
Haus
während hier die Aufräumarbeiten
beginnen bleiben viele Menschen auch
über Nacht auf der Straße aus Angst vor
noch mehr Nachbeben keiner weiß ob und
wie einsturzgefährdet die Häuser sind
ich bin erstmal zurück zu meinem Haus
gegangen und habe gesehen dass da viele
Risse in der Wand sind ich kann da nicht
schlafen ich weiß nicht wie groß das
Risiko ist da müsste ein Experte kommen
und mir sagen ob ich zurück kann oder
nicht
weiter südwestlich nahe des epizzentrums
hat das Erdbeben ganze Dörfer zerstört
Soldaten und Zivilisten Graben in den
Trümmern und hoffen Überlebende zu
finden ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
währenddessen wächst der Unmut bei den
Menschen das in vielen Gebieten Hilfe
nicht oder nur sehr langsam ankommt
Wasser und Essen wird vielerorts knapper
sind immer noch Menschen verschüttet die
haben nicht rechtzeitig die Hilfe
bekommen die sie brauchten deshalb sind
sie wohl gestorben meine Kinder konnte
ich retten und jetzt versuche ich Decken
oder irgendwas zum Anziehen für sie zu
bekommen
das Königshaus hat eine dreitägige
Staatstrauer ausgerufen aber vom König
keine Worte zum Volk wieder vor Ort noch
im Fernsehen
zahlreiche Staaten haben ihre Hilfe
angeboten ohne eine offizielle
Hilfsanfrage von Marokko aber können die
deutschen zum Beispiel nicht ins
Katastrophengebiet fliegen seit
Samstagabend standen die THW
Rettungskräfte bereit
inzwischen wurden immerhin 56 spanische
Rettungshelfer mit Spürhunden nach
Marokko entsandt und Feuerwehrleute aus
Frankreich für die Verletzten in den
überfüllten Krankenhäusern Spenden viele
Menschen Blut
ich habe nicht einmal darüber
nachgedacht sondern bin einfach hierher
gerannt denn eine der wichtigsten
Aufgaben eines Bürgers ist es sich
gegenseitig zu helfen vor allem unter
diesen Bedingungen hier unter den
Menschen sterben meine Tochter und ich
sind für ein paar Tage hier im Urlaub
wir lieben marathisch und wir haben im
Fernsehen auf Youtube und im
Nachrichtensender gesehen das ist ein
Aufruf zur blutspendet
die Zahl der Todesopfer steigt weiter
und das tatsächlicher Ausmaß dieser
Katastrophe ist noch immer nicht ganz
klar viele hier sind verzweifelt müssen
weiter in solchen improvisierten Camps
ausharren und auf Hilfe warten
so und offen hat der König Marokkos nun
doch eine Ansprache im Fernsehen
gehalten es kommen jetzt in diesen
Momenten entsprechende Meldungen rein
dass er sich für internationale Hilfe
bedankt und erklärt man habe erstmal
koordinieren müssen was man braucht und
man braucht aber Hilfe
wenn sie den Menschen in Marokko helfen
wollen dass Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe sammelt Spenden die
IBAN lautet
de65-100-400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Marokko Infos gibt es auch unter
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
in Neu Delhi ist der G20 Gipfel zu Ende
gegangen am glücklichsten über den
Verlauf scheint der Gastgeber zu sein
Indiens Präsident modedi er präsentierte
sich als einflussreichen Welten Lenker
und er schaffte es ein Eklat zu
verhindern zwischenzeitlich hat das ja
so ausgesehen als würde man gar keine
gemeinsame Abschlusserklärung kennen
bekommen das was man dann hinbekommen
hat ist allerdings bescheiden vor allem
die Ukraine die den Gipfel von der
Seitenlinie aus beobachtete zeigt sich
enttäuscht während sich der russische
Außenminister in Indien sichtlich wohler
fühlte als noch vor einem Jahr beim
Treffen auf Bali
darüber habe ich heute morgen mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz gesprochen bevor er
seine Rückreise antrat zuvor aber
erstmal der Bericht von Andreas Kühnast
am Tag 563 des Krieges steht Russlands
Außenminister lavroff neben Indiens
Ministerpräsident Modi und lässt sich
das Haus des vielleicht berühmtesten
Kriegsgegners der Welt zeigen
sergejabroff steht wie
selbstverständlich am Denkmal für
Mahatma Gandhi steht wie
selbstverständlich auf der Weltbühne
Michel Nauheim Moment silence please als
die G20 Schweigen nach zwei Tagen des
Streits ist lavroff ist Russland in ihre
Mitte zurückgekehrt Ministerpräsident
Modi hat den Westen den globalen Süden
und Russland in Neu-Delhi
zusammengebracht aber einander nicht
näher
Bundeskanzler Scholz und Finanzminister
Lindner konnten nicht sicher sein auch
nach den 200 vor verhandlungsstunden
ihrer Beamten nicht ob es überhaupt noch
mal eine G20 Erklärung geben wird und
überhaupt noch mal einen G20 Gipfel
vergangenes Jahr hatte die
Staatengemeinschaft Russland noch scharf
verurteilt diesmal wird Krieg nur
allgemein geächtet und territoriale
Integrität nur allgemein betont trotzdem
ist nicht nur Scholz fest entschlossen
es als Erfolg zu bezeichnen dass wir zu
Ergebnissen kommen die eben doch eine
Klarheit hergestellt haben an der dem
einen oder anderen ganz sicher nicht
gelegen war insbesondere der russischen
Regierung nicht
dieser G20 Gipfel bestätigt die
Isolierung Russlands die große Mehrheit
hat den Angriff auf die Ukraine und
seine Auswirkungen verurteilt
verurteilt isoliert Sagella broff muss
eine andere Erklärung gelesen haben
die westlichen Staatschefs scheinen die
Leute für naiv zu halten dieser Text
soll Russland verurteilen tut er nicht
Russland wird nicht einmal erwähnt gibt
auf den sorgfältig inszenierten
gipfelbildern an der spektakulären
Dinner Tafel ist lavroff nicht zu
erkennen weil Modi beiden macron und
Scholz nicht in Verlegenheit bringen
will bricht er mit einer G20 Tradition
ein Familienfoto wie in Rom wie in Osaka
wie in Buenos Aires wird es aus
Neu-Delhi nicht geben haben sie mit
seriellawrov gesprochen
nein hatten sie Gelegenheit mit einem
westlichen Staatslenker zu sprechen
ich habe die Gelegenheit nicht gesucht
es ist der Gipfel der verpassten
Gelegenheiten Joe Biden wäre gern einen
Schritt auf Chinas Präsident hi
zugegangen aber sie blieb lieber im
Peking ich hoffe dass ich Mister hier
früher als später zu sehen kriege
dann übergibt Indiens premiermodi das
G20 Hämmerchen an Brasiliens Präsident
Lula der umgehend Putin wissen ließ er
könne zum nächsten Treffen unbesorgt
kommen G20 Gipfel bleiben schwierig
und der Bundeskanzler ist uns was nur
Delhi zugeschaltet guten Tag Herr Scholz
guten Tag eine Abschlusserklärung über
die sich Russland freut und sagt das sei
schön ausgewogen für das die Sache nicht
eigentlich mit Blick auf die Ukraine
absurdum
die Abschlusserklärung ist zustande
gekommen weil viele Länder das wollten
in enger Kooperation zwischen dem Norden
und dem Süden Europa Nordamerika den
Ländern im Süden Amerikas in Asien und
den Afrika und wenn da nicht 18 Länder
gesagt hätten wir wollen jetzt eine
solche Beschließung fassen in der auch
die Integrität und Souveränität der
Ukraine
thematisiert wird und der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen verboten wird dann wird das
nicht zustande gekommen das hat Russland
am Ende hinnehmen müssen insofern zeigt
das dass der Eindruck ein wenig drückt
naja in Bali vor einem Jahr war
wenigstens noch die Rede davon dass die
Ukraine angegriffen wird und dass man
das verurteilt in dieser Erklärung wird
nicht mal mehr rosten und Reiter genannt
wenn ich mir vorstelle sie sind ein Teil
eines Landes das angegriffen wird das
täglich bombardiert wird um dessen
Städte vernichtet werden und dann steht
da nur bitte alle Beteiligten sollten
sich doch mal ein bisschen zurücknehmen
das ist aus Sicht von Kiew natürlich
furchtbar
dass sich aus der Sicht der Ukraine dann
noch mehr hätte stehen können es richtig
und übrigens wenn wir in Deutschland
darüber alleine diskutieren und im
Deutschen Bundestag eine Entschließung
verabschieden sind die auch anders aus
aber die haben sich 20 Staaten geeinigt
und ich will das noch mal betonen wäre
es nach Russland gegangen wäre das alles
gar nicht so formuliert worden sondern
nur der Druck viele andere hat dazu
beigetragen dass das am Ende auch
gelungen ist und das ist ja das
Besondere hier gibt es einstimmige
Entscheidung und keinen anderen Weg das
zu machen und deshalb war diese gute
Kooperation und dieser Druck notwendig
um so weit zu kommen
sie sagen zu so weit zu kommen am Ende
ist man ja auf den winzigsten
gemeinsamen Nenner gekommen fragt sich
da nicht so ein bisschen was solche
Erklärungen überhaupt noch bringen
das sind hier Zusammenkünfte der
bevölkerungsreichsten und
wirtschaftsstärksten
Nationen derjenigen aus den klassischen
Industrieländern vielen aus den globalen
Süden und dass wir uns über viele Fragen
miteinander unterhalten und verständigen
und das auch festhalten etwa wenn es um
den Schutz des Klimas und andere
Aufgaben gibt die wir gemeinsam haben
das ist wichtig und zentral und ich
glaube dass das jetzt trotz der ganzen
Skepsis im Vorfeld doch noch gelungen
ist etwas wo die indische
Ratspräsidentschaft sich was zu
unterhalten darf aber wo es auch die
neue Erfahrung gibt dass eine
Kooperation zwischen Nord- und Süd in
dieser Weise auch möglich ist und
natürlich ist das eben sind das 20
Länder von denen jedenfalls 18 klare
Meinung haben in die in der Frage und
das auch dann haben wir stark machen
können ich möchte Eindruck oder hat der
Einfluss des Westens darauf was dann bei
solchen Veranstaltungen eigentlich noch
herauskommt deutlich nachgelassen auch
sogar im letzten Jahr deutlich
nachgelassen wie gesagt in Bali war noch
sehr viel mehr möglich
aus meiner Sicht ist das eine
Fragestellung der bin ich nachgehen
sollten denn das was wir doch brauchen
für die Welt der Zukunft ist eine enge
Kooperation auch mit vielen Ländern des
globalen Südens und nicht das diese
Länder dem Westen folgen das kann nicht
funktionieren und das ist auch gar nicht
wünschbar und da denke ich schon dass da
was gelungen ist da dadurch dass wir in
vielen anderen Formaten sehr viele
Gespräche geführt haben mit Indonesien
zum Beispiel mit Indien mit Südafrika
mit Argentinien und Brasilien und diese
Länder waren auch alle dabei dafür zu
sorgen dass hier
Entscheidungen zustande kommen die zum
Beispiel von Russland nicht gern
unterschrieben worden wären und ich
finde das ist wichtig dass wir in dieser
Art und Weise miteinander kooperieren
die Welt wird sich ändern diese Länder
werden ökonomisch und von der größere
Bevölkerung hin immer wichtiger werden
und dass wir jetzt da miteinander
versuchen gemeinsam Politik für die Welt
zu formulieren das ist notwendig und dem
darf man auch nicht ausweichen
nee auf keinen Fall die sind nämlich
auch nicht ausgewichen also sie die
Außenministerin der Wirtschaftsminister
sie sind ja durch diesen globalen Süden
getourt quasi und haben wirklich auch
versucht die die die westliche Sicht die
deutsche Sicht die Sicht auf diesen
Angriffskrieg in Europa deutlich zu
machen aber es scheint nicht so viel
gefruchtet zu haben also wenn ich sage
hat er Einfluss
nachgelassen meine ich nicht müde Westen
sag dem globalen Süden was er zu denken
hat aber es ist offenbar dem diesen
globalen Süden doch auch relativ egal
was ich hier in Europa abspielt zu lang
weiterhin Handel getrieben werden kann
und ähnliches damit muss man ja
irgendwie umgehen
ja also vielleicht darf ich mal an Ihre
Frage anknüpfen sie haben ja dann lange
gesagt warum das alles keinen Einfluss
des Westens ist und dann haben sie ja
hinzugefügt naja das kann man ja auch
nicht sagen dass der Westen den anderen
einfach sagt was sie zu denken und zu
tun haben und das ist ja auch das Thema
deshalb finde ich müssen wir mit der
Bewertung solcher Zusammenkünfte eine
anders umgehen wir müssen das
Vorantreiben worum es uns geht das eine
Welt in der auch viele Länder groß und
wichtig und bedeutend werden mit denen
wir auch gerne kooperieren mit denen wir
übrigens auch gerne Geschäfte machen und
die wir exportieren wollen nach
Indonesien nach Indien das Gute
Wachstumszahlen hat und viele andere
Länder dann müssen wir da auch jetzt auf
Augenhöhe miteinander politisch sprechen
und natürlich sind die Blickwinkel aus
der ganzen Welt sehr unterschiedlich und
das gehört ja gerade deshalb
zu den Errungenschaften der G20 dass man
das an einem Tisch miteinander beredet
und das wird glaube ich nicht
überschätzt werden kann das ist wichtig
also eigentlich war zwei nicht Mann mit
dem Tisch und denke ich mal froh dass
ich mit dem Tisch war aber Präsident hi
aus Peking ist nicht angereist was sagt
uns das
zunächst mal China war vertreten und
zwar durch den Regierungschef der da war
und der die Positionen Chinas vertreten
hat ganz klar ist aber das nach diesem
Gipfel für viele sehr deutlich geworden
sein wird das ist wirklich ein zentrale
Austauschort in der Welt wo miteinander
gesprochen und verhandelt wird und ich
bin auch froh dass übrigens noch viele
andere Länder hier als Gäste dabei waren
die auch an Bedeutung gewinnen werden
und noch gar nicht zu den G20
dazugehören ein Fortschritt ist ja zum
Beispiel dass die Afrikanische Union
jetzt Mitglied geworden ist ob das ein
Zeichen dafür dass wir diesen Ort
brauchen und das werden auch andere
verstehen ja schon aber sie hat lieber
Dörfer in China besucht als zum 20
Gipfel zu sehen zu gehen damit wir uns
ja allen etwas sagen oder
ich spekuliere über solche Fragen nicht
china hat außerdem vor kurzem eine
offizielle Landkarte veröffentlicht auf
der man eben Territorium von Russland
Indien Taiwan mit einverleibt wurde ist
das die nächste kriegsregion auf die man
sich einstellen muss
das
wollen wir nicht hoffen und so ist das
auch nicht so sieht das auch nicht aus
ich glaube wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
es keine militärischen Konflikte gibt um
Grenzen zu ordnen in Anführungsstrichen
und wie schlimm und bitter das ist das
Russland sein imperialen Krieg führt
weil es einfach sein Territorium auf
Kosten der Ukraine erweitern will das
sieht ja nun auch jeder Joe beiden war
da sie haben sie mit ihm darüber
gesprochen dass es Berichte gibt es ja
attack MS eventuell demnächst liefert
und was würde das dann für die deutsche
taurusdebatte bedeuten
wir haben uns über viele Fragen
unterhalten über diese nicht
ja danke für das Gespräch
schönen Dank
Videos und Hintergründe zum G20 Gipfel
finden Sie bei uns natürlich auch online
auf ZDF heute
so gleich kommen wir dann auch zu den
sportlichen Ereignissen dieses Tages
aber vorher gibt es noch einige
politische Nachrichten eins der
US-Präsident beiden ist vom G20-Gipfel
in Indien nach Vietnam gereist
Washington bemüht sich in Südostasien
ein stärkeres Gegengewicht zum
wachsenden Einfluss Chinas zu schaffen
beiden und die vietnamesische Führung
vereinbarten eine engere Zusammenarbeit
in Form einer strategischen
Partnerschaft er sagte es gehe ihm darum
Bündnisse zu stärken und damit für
internationale Stabilität zu sorgen und
nicht um meine Eindämmung Chinas
bei einem russischen Angriff in der Nähe
der ostukrainischen Stadt bachmut sind
nach Angaben einer
Nichtregierungsorganisation zwei ihrer
Mitarbeiter getötet worden zwei weitere
darunter ein deutscher wurden schwer
verletzt russland hat auch die
ukrainische Hauptstadt Kiew wieder mit
zahlreichen Drohnen angegriffen die
Abwehr habe die meisten Flugkörper
abgefangen teilte das ukrainische
Militär mit durch Trümmerteile wurden
eine Person verletzt und Wohnhäuser
beschädigt
die saarländische Ministerpräsidentin
Rehlinger SPD drängt in der Diskussion
um einen befristeten brückenstrompreis
für energieintensive Unternehmen auf
eine möglichst schnelle Entscheidung in
der ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt verwies
relinger auf den internationalen
Wettbewerb es gehe um Tausende von
Arbeitsplätzen die 16 Bundesländer
hatten sich angesichts gestiegene
Energiekosten geschlossen für einen
befristeten Strompreis ausgesprochen
der Präsident des Zentralverbands des
deutschen Handwerks Dietrich fordert von
der Politik mehr Unterstützung für die
Baubranche die Baufinanzierungen für
künftige Projekte sein massiv
eingebrochen wenn die Politik nicht
gegensteuere werde sich das im Abbau von
Kapazitäten niederschlagen sagte
Dietrich der Bild am Sonntag das
Baugewerbe mit seinen 2,3 Millionen
Beschäftigten sei eine Schlüsselbranche
für das Handwerk
am letzten Tag der internationalen Auto-
und mobilitätsmesse IAA hat es in
München wieder Demonstrationen gegen die
Messe gegeben hunderte iaa-gegner
versammelten sich in der bayerischen
Landeshauptstadt sie fordern unter
anderem mehr Klimaschutz aufgerufen zu
den Protestaktionen hatten mehrere
Organisationen
oder zuletzt ja viel gemeckert über den
deutschen Spitzensport dabei hat
Deutschland einen fantastischen
erfahrenen Bundestrainer und eine
großartige junge Nationalmannschaft im
Basketball eine Mannschaft die sprüht
die will die einen bärenstarken Kapitän
und Teamgeist hat und jetzt sogar
Weltmeister geworden ist was wirklich
unglaublich ist das gab es noch nie das
ist historisch
über das Wunder von Manila
unglaublich aber wahr der Pokal für die
Weltmeister dieser Triumph zweifellos
eine Überraschung aber hier feiert die
beste und einzig ungeschlagene
Mannschaft dieser WM
das hier ist auf jeden Fall einer meiner
besten Momente in meinem Leben das mit
denen mein teammates zu feiern mit
meinem Coach zu feiern mit meiner
Familie zu feiern
wir haben Geschichte geschrieben und das
Endspiel an Spannung kommt zu überbieten
zuerst Serbien das bessere Team liegt
nach dem ersten Viertel in Führung doch
Deutschland bleibt dran Franz Wagner
nach dieser tollen einwurf-variante zum
38 zu 37 es geht hin und her eine
Weltklasse Aktion von Bogdan Bogdanovic
aus der Rückwärtsbewegung welch ein
Dreier
doch Weltniveau hat auch Dennis Schröder
zu bieten ein Stil
ein Dunking spielerische Perfektion
das dritte Viertel eine Drangphase der
deutschen herrlicher Spiel Zug die
Führung zum ersten Mal zwei stelle ich
64 zu 53 aber Serbien kommt zurück auch
dank Abramowitsch der insgesamt 21
Punkte erzielt
Deutschland in der Schlussphase nur noch
zwei vor doch es kommt die Zeit von
Dennis Schröder der Kapitän
unwiderstehlich zum Korb 81 zu 77 enorm
wichtig
28 Punkte schaffte insgesamt und er
setzt auch den Schlusspunkt 83 zu 77 und
dann ist alles nur noch grenzenlose
Euphorie Deutschland Weltmeister
irgendwie und fassbar
also ich check noch nicht mal dass wir
jetzt Weltmeister sind ich brauche
mindestens noch eine Stunde Tage bis das
bis ich das hier wirklich realisiere
Dennis Schröder wird auch noch zum
besten Spieler des Turniers gewählt mehr
Erfolg für Deutschland geht nicht aber
ist er auch nachhaltig
es war einfach dass der Deutsche Bahn
weiter weg dass wir mehr Fans mehr
Spieler an sich kriegen und Spielerinnen
und ähm ja einfach dass der Sport ein
größere größere Reichweite hat
[Musik]
im Blick zu genießen
und wie die Feier weitergehen könnte
deutet sich schon während der
Pressekonferenz an wird wohl feucht
fröhlich
[Applaus]
die Basketballer zeigen jedenfalls alles
was der Fußballnationalmannschaft gerade
fehlt ausgerechnet in die letzten
Minuten des packenden
basketballfinales schickte der DFB die
Meldung das Hansi Flick freigestellt
wurde vielleicht auch nicht gerade das
was man als Gefühl für sportliches
Timing bezeichnen würde der Rauswurf des
Bundestrainers ist übrigens auch
historisch seine Vorgänger waren alle
mehr oder weniger freiwillig selbst
gegangen das flixtage bezelt waren
konnte man allerdings spätestens seit
gestern Ahnen nach dem Auftritt gegen
Japan Beruf Büchler berichtet
Endstation Wolfsburg die Entlassung
kommt nicht wirklich überraschend nach
nur vier Siegen aus den letzten 17
Spielen es ist ein skurriler Sonntag da
lässt der DFB Hansi Flick noch das
öffentliche Training gleiten und
Autogramme schreiben um ihn dann wenige
Stunden später doch vom Hof zu jagen am
Tag nach der Blamage gibt es im Team
Hotel mehr Krisensitzungen als
Torchancen gegen Japan am frühen Abend
dringt dann nach außen das Flick ein
ziemlich ehemaliger Bundestrainer ist
die Bosse waren sich einig dass die
Trennung unumgänglich sei steht in der
Pressemitteilung die Mannschaft brauche
einen neuen Impuls vor der EM im eigenen
Land eine Aufbruchstimmung und
Zuversicht so Präsident Neuendorf dabei
gab sich der seit Monaten schwer
angezelte flieg gestern noch kämpferisch
wir sind davon überzeugt von dem was wir
machen und ja deswegen geht's auch so
weiter für mich
es ging nicht weiter und Völler
verzichtete bereits gestern auf ein
klares Bekenntnis zum Bundestrainer
aber wie gesagt im Moment wir tun gut
daran erstmal eine Nacht drüber zu
schlafen bevor wir jetzt irgendwelche
Analysen machen das zum Spiel unter
Flick blieb der so dringend benötigte
Stimmungsumschwung aus Dienstag gegen
Frankreich werden Völler DFB
nachwuchsdirektor Hannes Wolf und
Ex-Nationalspieler Sandro Wagner die
Nationalelf einmalig betreuen erst
danach soll die Nachfolge von Flick
geregelt werden das heute hinter
verschlossenen Türen Völler zum
übergangscoach gemacht wurde beweist die
unvorbereitet der DFB auf die aktuellen
Entwicklung war nach dem kläglichen
Scheitern bei der WM und dem danach
völlig missratenen Kurs ist nun der
absolute Stimmung Tiefpunkt erreicht
auch die sportliche Lage
besorgniserregend und das 9 Monate vor
der EM bei der flieg dann nicht mehr
dabei sein wird
noch etwas nachbearbeiten Nils Karben
steht in Wolfsburg und zwar da wo der
DFB auf seiner Krisensitzung heute die
Entscheidung getroffen hat Nils warum
hat das nicht geklappt zwischen der
Nationalmannschaften woran lags
zum einen hat es ganz einfach daran
gelegen dass nach der enttäuschenden
Weltmeisterschaft im letzten Wind der
die Mannschaft in diesem Jahr sechs
Länderspiele bestritten hat und davon
nur ein einziges gewonnen hat im März
gegen Peru zuletzt gab es sogar drei
Niederlagen nacheinander so was hat es
in der DFB Geschichte zuletzt 1985
gegeben also vor fast 40 Jahren so ein
Stachel sitzt tief vor allen Dingen aber
hat glaube ich den Ausschlag gegeben wir
haben es gerade in den Beitrag gehört
dass das Vertrauen verloren gegangen ist
das Hansi fliegt der richtige Mann sein
könnte um das Ruder noch rumzureißen
neun Monate sind noch bis zur
Weltmeister bis zur Europameisterschaft
im eigenen Land und die
gastgebergemeinschaft gibt an dieser
ströses Bild ab so konnte es nicht
weitergehen und deshalb hat die haben
die dfb-chefs gestern die Notbremse
gezogen viele haben gesagt das hätten
sie besser schon direkt nach dem WM aus
tun sollen wahrscheinlich hatte das ja
vor zwei Jahren ganz gut angefangen mit
mit
hat sogar sehr gut angefangen mit acht
Spielen nacheinander die ja alle
gewonnen hat zur Wahrheit gehört
allerdings dazu dass die Gegner
Lichtenstein hießen und nordmazedonien
und Israel bei allem Respekt
schwierig wurde ist vor ungefähr einem
Jahr aber daheim Niederlage in Leipzig
gegen Ungarn wie die WM ausgegangen ist
haben alle noch in guter Erinnerung vor
zwei Tagen ist eine Insider
Dokumentation veröffentlicht worden und
wer die angeschaut hat kann sehen das
haben sie Flick auch bei den Ansprachen
bei mannschaftssitzungen in der Kabine
nicht in aller überzeugendsten Eindruck
hinterlassen hat sowas bleibt ja
normalerweise geheim jetzt kann es jeder
sehen und das hat am Ende dann zu der
Überzeugung geführt dass die Mannschaft
immer mehr verunsichert worden ist durch
taktische Experimente durch personelle
Entscheidungen die nicht alle immer
nachvollziehen konnten und deswegen das
aus heute Nachmittag dann noch mal ganz
kurz nach vorne geguckt wer ist jetzt so
der heißeste Anwärter auf die Nachfolge
dabei muss man immer gucken wer ist denn
überhaupt verfügbar der große
Wunschkandidat ist und bleibt natürlich
Jürgen Klopp aber jeder weiß der hat
einen Vertrag in Liverpool steht also
nicht zur Verfügung jetzt ist Julian
nagelsmann der ja im Frühjahr bei den
Bayern entlassen worden ist der heißeste
Kandidat der ist allerdings erst 36
Jahre alt da muss man mal gucken ob die
Chemie stimmt zwischen DFB und
nagelsmann außerdem ist er noch unter
Vertrag bei den Bayern ob man sich da
einigen kann das werden wir in den
nächsten Tagen erleben Rudi Völler macht
es tatsächlich nur für dieses eine Spiel
übermorgen gegen den Vize-Weltmeister
wenn man den äh gestern gesehen hat wie
fertig der allein schon vom zugucken war
dann muss einem Angst im Bange werden
aber dass da gut übersteht am Donnerstag
am Dienstag in Dortmund aber wir werden
in den nächsten Tagen klarer sie
nagelsmann ist im Moment der Favorit
danke schön Nils nach Wolfsburg
und mit Sport geht's jetzt bei dir auch
noch mal weiter unter anderem mit der
Ruder WM in Belgrad da gab es zum
Abschluss für das deutsche Team meine
Goldmedaille in einer triumphierte
Oliver Zeitler und holte sich den WM
Titel zum dritten Mal und für den in
Deutschland Achter gab es zwar keine
Medaille er konnte sich aber durch Rang
fünf für die Olympischen Spiele im
nächsten Jahr qualifizieren
Dressurreiterin Jessica von Bredo Werndl
hat bei der Europameisterschaft den
Riesenbeck das zweite Einzelgold
gewonnen die 37-Jährige kam auch in der
Kür auf Platz 1 und verteidigte damit
noch nach dem Grand Prix Spezial am
Freitag auch den zweiten EM-Titel
bei der Ironman Weltmeisterschaft in
Nizza hat Triathlet Patrick lange die
Silbermedaille gewonnen der 37-Jährige
musste sich nur dem Franzosen Sam
lightlow geschlagen geben dritter wurde
Magnus Detlef aus Dänemark abgeschlagen
als 24 kam Triathlon Superstar Jan Frau
Dino beim letzten Rennen in seiner
Karriere ins Ziel empfangen wurde der
42-Jährige Olympiasieger und dreimalige
Ironman Weltmeister dort vom
diesjährigen Vize-Weltmeister lange
ab nächste Woche schon ein neuer
Bundestrainer benannt wird wissen wir
nicht kann natürlich gut sein dass das
noch etwas länger dauert für die
Basketballer wird es auf jeden Fall
einen weltmeisterlichen Empfang geben
wenn sie nach Deutschland zurückkehren
und dann gibt es noch ein paar
Ereignisse die jetzt schon vorhersehbar
sind ein Ausblick darauf von
[Musik]
es ist das zentrale Infrastrukturprojekt
der Energiewende der Bau der Stromtrasse
südlink am Montag wird der offizielle
Spatenstich erfolgen 700 Kilometer lang
durch sechs Bundesländer soll die Trasse
den Strom vom Norden in den Süden
bringen gegen das milliardenschwere
Projekt hatte es lange Widerstand
gegeben der Oberste Gerichtshof Israels
wird sich am Dienstag mit der
umstrittenen Justizreform beschäftigen
die rechtsreligiöse netanjaro Regierung
hatte die Handlungsmöglichkeiten des
Gerichts stark eingeschränkt kritiker
sehen darin eine Gefahr für Israels
Demokratie und protestieren seit Monaten
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
wird am Mittwoch zur Lage der
Europäischen Union sprechen wohl selten
waren die Herausforderungen aber auch
die Erwartungen so groß wie dieses Mal
die zentralen Themen ihrer Rede Klima
Krieg und die anstehende Europawahl
es ist wieder wiesenzeit in München am
kommenden Samstag wird das 188
Oktoberfest feierlich eröffnet wenig
erhitzt die Gemüter auf der Wiesen so
sehr wie der Preis für die Maß Bier und
der dürfte so einigen bitter aufstoßen
liegt er doch erstmals bei über 14 Euro
und so sind die Wetteraussichten zum
Start in die neue Woche morgen ist es
zunächst sonnig zum Abend bilden sich
Schauer und Gewitter im Nordwesten und
westlich des Rheins ungewöhnlich heißt
bei 25 bis 34 Grad am Dienstag ziehen
kräftige Gewitter mit starkregend durch
und auch der Mittwoch ist noch
unbeständig 18 bis 31 Grad
das war von uns an diesem Sonntagabend
gleich geht's mit Kommissar Beck weiter
und um 0 Uhr 30 gibt es dann die nächste
heute Express und hier erwarten Sie
morgen Abend und Hanna Zimmermann auf
Wiedersehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]